Want to make a discord bot that talks like
characters from Rick and Morty or Harry Potter?
Maybe you want to make a talk like another
favorite character.
In this course Lynn will show you how to create
a discord bot that uses artificial intelligence
to talk like a character of your choice.
Hi there.
I'm Lynn.
I'm a software engineer, hobbyist game developer
and recent graduate from the University of
Chicago.
In this tutorial, we're going to build a discord
AI chat bot that can speak like your favorite
character.
Before we start, if you haven't seen that
video, by any chance, know that this video
is something different and more comprehensive.
So keep watching to the end, the original
tutorial and my first discord bot started
as a joke between me and my friends when we
were playing video games, and it really surprised
me how popular it became and a lot of people
wanted to build their own bot based on that
tutorial.
Therefore, I decided to update that tutorial
to include more characters, as well as to
show you how to find data for your favorite
character.
Other topics that we will cover here include,
but are not limited to how to train the model,
how to deploy the model, come the errors you
might see during this model, training and
deployment pipeline and how to solve them.
Moreover, we will cover how to build the bot
in Python and how to build it in JavaScript.
Lastly, we will cover how to properly deploy
the bot to a Discord server and to limit it
to certain channels, and how to keep the bot
running indefinitely.
I hope you're excited.
And let's jump into the tutorial.
First, we're going to find data for our character.
My favorite sources aren't kaggle transcript
wiki, and just random fandom websites that
came out from a Google search.
And my research process goes like this, I
first search on kaggle to see if there are
pre made dialog data set.
For example, if we search for Rick and Morty,
we get this nicely formatted data set that
includes the name of the character and the
lines are speaking.
If we search for Harry Potter, here is another
data set that includes the character and the
sentence they're speaking.
Since we're building a chatbot, we need only
these two columns in our data, set the character
name and align their speaking.
So these dialog data sets on kaggle are perfect
for our requirement.
Alright, if we succeeded in finding some data
on kaggle, we can move on to the model training
step.
But what if we cannot find a data set for
our character on kaggle.
For example, if I want to find a data set
for Peppa Pig, it looks like there is no data
set for the character.
In this case, we may need to find a raw transcript
of the media, be it a video game, a cartoon
on a show.
And I've found that transcript wiki has some
great resources.
So here we have a list of movies shows, video
games, musicals commercials.
For example, I was able to find the transcript
for Peppa Pig.
And also movies like Batman on transcript
wiki.
The transcript looks like this.
So we have their character name and their
actions or the lines they're speaking.
We will see shortly how to turn a raw transcript
like this into a data set like those we saw
on kaggle.
Besides transcript wiki, you may also just
Google the name of your media with the keyword
transcript.
For example, my first thought was based on
the game, the word ends with you.
And it has no results either on kaggle or
transcript wiki.
So what I did was to just Google the name
of the game and game transcript.
And it just happened that this fandom website
has the full game transcript.
So Be sure to utilize your Google Search skills
to find data for your character.
If rather than a fictional character, you
are more interested in real life character,
you may search for interview scripts as your
data source.
If you want to create a chatbot that speaks
like yourself or your friends, you can treat
text messages between you and your friends
as dialogues, and handcraft, your data set.
There are tons of ways to get data for your
character.
So be creative.
And now we will look at how to turn raw transcripts
into data set.
Now, suppose we have found our raw transcript,
let's see how we can turn it into a two column
character line data set.
Suppose we take this Peppa Pig transcripts
and copy them into a text file.
Now we go to Google colab and upload our data
file.
Now we create a Google colab notebook.
And use those to parse our script.
So I'm going to name this parse script ipnb.
And we are going to from Google colab can
import drive and then called drive about mount
content drive.
This will allow us to read the data from our
Google Drive.
Alright, now that our drive has been mounted,
let's import OS and then OS change directory
into content, drive by drive.
And then we see if there's anything in it.
Yeah, we have our Peppa Pig dot txt.
So here we are going to import regular expression
to parse our transcript, put the parsed result
into a panda's data frame, and export it as
a CSV file just like those we saw on kaggle.
This is going to be our regular expression
pattern.
You don't have to be a pro a regular expression
to understand this part.
If we take the pattern to this site, and our
testing is Peppa Pig
you will see that we have two match capture
groups, the first being the character's name,
the second being the line spoken.
And also for the second line mama pig, we
have the character name and the line being
spoken.
Right so that's all right, regular expression.
Now, let's define a dictionary that will store
our data.
So we know that we need the column name and
the column line in our result data frame
and then we open and read the file
For each line, we match it with our regular
expression pattern.
If there is a match, we extract name and light
from this regular expression match, and then
append it to our dictionary here.
And then we convert this dictionary into a
data frame.
Now we can inspect the data frame, quote.
So we have the name is Peppa Pig saying that
I'm Peppa Pig.
And George makes the sound that mama pig makes
the sound great.
We can also count the number of lines that
belong to our character.
So we do some the F name is equal to Peppa
Pig.
And we saw that Peppa Pig has 38 lines in
our entire data frame.
So the length of our data frame is over 100
and Peppa Pig has 1/3 of the lines.
The last step will be to export the data frame.
So df.to, CSV, the name will be Peppa Pig.
csv and and we will drop the index.
Cool.
Now we should have a Peppa Pig dot CSV in
overdrive.
And hear this name and line.
This is how we parse those raw transcripts
into a file that can be used in our model
training.
So next, let's proceed on to the exciting
step model training.
Now we're going to train the model.
Go to my GitHub repository linked to in the
description below and download the content.
We're going to use those model train upload
workflow the IP one MB which looks like this.
Alright, now our file has been downloaded,
we unzip the content.
And in here we have a model training upload
workflow dot ipnb.
We upload this notebook file to Google Drive
and open it in Google colab.
We are going to train a GPT model which is
short for generative pre trained transformer.
In the runtime change runtime type.
Make sure to select GPU because this will
accelerate our model training.
So now here we mount the drive.
We install the Transformers module that we'll
be using.
And we change directory into my drive.
Here are all the modules that we are importing.
If we're using the data set from kaggle, we
need to obtain our API key from kaggle.
So go to our kaggle profile, go to account.
Scroll down to the API key section.
Create a new API token and download this file
as kaggle dot JSON.
We'll go back to Google Drive and upload kaggle
dot JSON.
Now we can download our data set from kaggle,
we're going to use the Harry Potter data set
as the example.
So grab those user name and the data set name.
And our file is here part one dot CSV.
Not not because there are white spaces, in
our file name, we got special characters in
the file name.
So let's inspect the contents of our data
file.
Well, CSV files are usually separated by commas,
hence the name CSV.
However, this one looks like it's separated
by semicolons.
So we need to take care of the semi colons
where we're reading the data into a panda's
data frame.
So separation is semicolon instead of a comma.
Cool.
So let's sample data to see what's inside.
Alright, so we have character and sentence.
Notice that these two column names aren't
exactly what we need.
We want the two columns of our data frame
to be named as name and line as use down here
in this cell, so we need to change the name
of our columns.
Alright, let's resample our data.
Looks like we have successfully changed the
name of our columns.
Now let's see how big our data is.
So he only has 1000 or so lines.
And let's see how many lines our character
has.
Our character has 155 lines.
So here we change our character name to Harry.
And we now run this cell to create a context
data frame that includes the current line
our characters speaking, and several lines
directly preceding the line.
Context data frame is useful here because
we are creating a conversational chatbot.
And we want to generate a response based on
the conversation context.
So let's sample our context data frame.
So in the context of clarity, something something
our character respond with seems a pity not
to ask her.
Great, now we have our data set, which split
the data set into a training set and a test
set.
This is because we don't want to overfit the
model.
In the case of overfitting, the model will
just memorize the lines from the data set
and talk back to us using the exact lines,
we don't want that we want the conversation
to be more organic.
So we're only training the model on a training
set and evaluating the model on the test set.
So we continue running these cells to build
data sets, caching checkpoints, and down here
we built the model.
We'll build our model by fine tuning Microsoft's
pre trained GPT small.
Small here refers to the number of parameters
in the model.
There are also a medium and a large model.
Generally, the larger the model, the longer
it takes to train, but the smarter the model
can get.
I would recommend that training a medium model,
as it's pretty smart and not too hard to change.
My production chatbot that is currently running
on a server with 1000 plus users is also a
medium model.
For this tutorial for the sake of time, I'm
training just a small model.
You can see here it's downloading the model.
And this may take some time because it's essentially
300 megabytes.
Here are some hyper parameters that you may
find useful.
For example, num train aprox is the number
of training aprox.
This is defined to be four here, and this
is the number of times that the model will
cycle through the training set.
As long as the model is not overfitting, increasing
the number of training epochs usually results
in smarter models.
Because the model has more time to cycle through
the data set and pick up the nitty gritty
details.
There's another hyper parameter called the
batch size.
This is the number of training examples that
the model will see in the batch before he
updates his gradient.
I wouldn't recommend changing this unless
you know what you're doing, since other hyper
parameters like learning rate and temperature
might be sensitive to this change in batch
size.
However, if you're training a larger model
on a larger data set and are running into
memory errors, to make the error go away a
might help to decrease the batch size.
The remaining cells have been configured to
taking this context data frame we've created,
trained the model and save it to a folder
called output small.
Now let's run this main function.
training will take some time, I trained my
medium model for 12 epochs, and it took around
two hours.
So do sit back and grab a snack while the
model is training.
You can see the progress in the progress bars
about Alright, here we get back a perplexing
cancer.
This usually refers to how confused the model
is.
If a model has a large complexity, it means
that the model is pretty confused as to which
words to choose to respond to a given situation.
And the model might not be very smart.
In our case, our data set is pretty small.
It only has 150 plus lines.
So it makes sense about the perplexity is
high to decrease the perplexity we might need
to train for more epochs.
Cool.
But now that the training is complete, we
can load and chat with the model here.
That's changed the name of the Hello, fellow
read writer.
So let's ask pause.
Quidditch.
There's no such thing as a bad read writer.
Great, it looks like our chat bots is capable
of making and maintaining a conversation.
Now we can push the model to Huggy face and
start building our discord chat bot.
Alright, now let's change directory just into
the content folder.
Because we'll be doing our push there.
And we do pip install hugging face command
line client.
And then we're logging using our credentials.
Right after logging were assigned this token,
we need to grab this token Go for the song
that we need to do afterwards.
So we can create a repository to store all
models from the command line, my is going
to be called dialogue up at small Harry Potter.
And our empty model repository is right here.
There's nothing except for the get attributes
file, but we will be adding the model file
soon.
Now we still get Fs, which stands for get
large file storage, this wall allows us to
push and pull all models.
And we've replaced this token with the takeaway
just copied from the above.
So here's my username and my token.
And we call it our training result is stored
in this output small directory.
And then we change directory into our dialog
up the small directory because we need to
do git add and permit from there, we saw the
get Fs and inspect the contents our current
directory, which should be dialogue GPT, small
her father and also just printed out the working
directory where to make sure that we are inside
content.
Cool.
Now we check the file status on Git.
So these files not we need to add to get.
So we do a git add this will take some time
because the pytorch model dot being is pretty
large.
And we configured a global username and user
email.
These are just my hug and based credentials.
That would come in with message initial comment.
And finally, we'll push the model.
It's about 400 megabytes because the pytorch
model is itself about 400 megabytes.
Alright, looks like the push is complete.
Now we see our pytorch model here.
However, there's one more thing that we need
to do before we can converse with the model
on Huggy face.
That is, you see here, it's tagged as text
generation.
However, we know that we are training a chatbot
model, and we want our model to be conversational.
For that purpose, we need to edit the model
card.
So we create a model cart here and we're putting
our desired model tax so our tax is conversational.
We come in our model card.
And now our model is correctly tagged as conversational.
If we go to the main model page, we can start
chatting with the model here.
Alright, now that we have pushed our model
to hugging face, we're ready to use it in
our discord chat bots.
Now we have our model let's build the discord
bot here on Discord.
I have my server lease dev lab.
I have two channels, one for the Python bot
and one for the job as robot The reason why
we have separate channel for the bots is because
we don't want the bots to be talking to each
other.
So after we built the bot, we will learn how
to set their permissions correctly so that
they don't go outside of their dedicated channel.
So we go to discord, developers page, create
an application, we need one application per
bot.
So our name will be chatted about Python.
So here we create a bot.
And I'm going to name this Harry Potter, bot,
Python and upload an icon.
We will be using this API token here.
When we create our bot in Python, we're going
to host our bot our rapida it so sign up for
repple.id and create a new Python repple here
going to name those chatty, but I thought
and in here, we will need to store our API
tokens for Huggy face underscore us environmental
variables.
So here is the top for the secrets for the
environment variables.
So the first one will be hugging face token.
And for the value, we'll go to our hugging
face profile or the profile API tokus, copy
the API token, come back here and fill in
that value.
Next, we'll created this core token.
And for this value, would go to this discord
developers portal and copy the token.
Three, add the token here.
And our environment variables are all set.
Next, I have the Python file in my GitHub
repository called this court bot dot p y.
So we brought the code from here, and I'll
explain the code line by line.
Starting from line one, we're first import
the OS module that will help us reading our
environment variables.
Next, we import modules that are useful for
querying the Huggy face model.
Finally, we'll import the discount module.
And here I have my API URL pointing to my
username.
And with the Find a bot as follows.
In the init function, it takes in a model
name, which for me will be dialogue GPT small
Harry Potter.
Then we store this API endpoint by concatenating
this API URL, which is my profile link with
the model name.
Now we retrieve the secret API token from
the system environment by looking at Oh s
dot environment hugging face token.
Next, we format the header, you know request
to Huggy face.
For the authorization part.
We're putting bearer and the hugging face
token.
Next, we'll define the quorum method that
takes in the payload. we dump the payload
as a JSON string.
And use the request module to make an HTTP
POST request to the API endpoint using our
defined request headers, which contains our
hugging face API key and passing the data.
Once the request finishes, it should give
us a response object and we decode it from
UTF eight and load the result as us rate and
return to string.
Next, would you find an asynchronous function
named already.
The next two function definitions are based
on the discord API.
Both are asynchronous function.
The first one is already, this function will
be called when the bot is logging in.
So when the bot is logging, we will print
out logged as print out the bots name and
a bot ID so that we know that the bot is functioning.
Next, because our bot is a chatbot, it needs
to respond to messages.
So our message is a method that will be called
each time the bot sees a message in the channel.
So given the message, if the message is coming
from the bot itself, the bot ignores the message
and does not reply to it.
Otherwise, it will form a Korea payload with
the content of the message.
And to make the bot more user friendly.
While the bot is waiting for the HTTP response
from the model, we set its status as typing
so that the user will know that the bot is
generating its response.
So this is a synchronous call with a message.channel.tv.
We call it soft query using the payload and
get back the response.
If there is a valid generated response, there
will be a generated tax field in this response.
And we'll be able to get that out as a bots
response.
Otherwise, there might be an error in the
response, we just log out the error message
so that we can debug later on.
Finally, we use another asynchronous method
to send the bots response to the channel using
message dot channel dot send.
And that's it about our bot definition.
In the main function we just created about
passing the model name.
So for me, this is style gptc small Harry
Potter
and us client that run looking up the score
token from the environment variables.
Great now that our bot should be all set up
that seemed like the bot to our channel.
In the OAuth two tab, we are going to select
the bot.
And for the bot permissions.
The only thing you need is to send messages.
So we copy this URL, paste it in a new browser
window and invited to my server.
Alright, now that we see that our bot has
appeared, however, it shows as offline.
So we need to run the repple.
So we hit run here.
And rapport is installing all our dependencies
and imports.
Great now that our bot has logged in as Harry
Potter about Python, and this is its unique
ID.
Let's go to the server.
And now that the bot is online don't want
the bot to appear in the general channel.
So we go to the channel setting permissions.
Advanced permissions add a bot
and we remove it permission to send messages
and save the changes.
Now, let's see what happens if I type something
in the general channel, nothing should happen
because the bot shouldn't be able to send
a message.
Nothing happens, although the bot is online.
And now this bot should work in this Python
bots channel.
So let's do Hello.
And we briefly saw not there's a typing prompt.
Cool.
So yeah, this is how we built a bot in Python.
One thing to know, you know, raphoe, though
it is not, because we took away the bots permission
to send the messages in the general channel,
it is showing an exception, and this is totally
okay.
If you don't like seeing this exception, you
can use the try, accept block and log out
this exception.
Great.
So now we're going to repeat the process for
the JavaScript bot.
So we go back to the discord developer portal,
and create a new application.
This time, I'm going to call it chatty bots,
JavaScript.
And I'll create a bot.
Back to wrap it, we create a node.js app.
going to call it chadic, thought js.
We again create two environmental variables.
The first one is hugging face token, copying
my API token from my profile Edit Profile,
putting here and copy my discord bot token.
Call this one this court token and adding
the value.
Great.
Now we have our environment variable set up.
Go to my GitHub repository, there is a discord
bots.js file that contains the code that we
will use for this JavaScript chatbot.
Let's copy paste.
And I'll go through the code line by line.
So first, we import the discord CPI for the
JavaScript module.
And we import fetch for making HTTP requests,
just like with it in Python.
And we initialize a new discord client and
define the model URL just as my user name
and the model name.
So this guy is the LGBT small Harry Potter.
And this is the same callback that is called
when the bot is ready, just like the already
function we saw in Python.
So when the bot is ready, and logged in, we
print out logged in as client user dot Tak.
And here is another callback.
This time all message, we use an asynchronous
callback, because we are making HTTP requests.
Like in the Python script, we ignore the message
if the message is from the bot itself.
By checking if message dot author is the bot.
Now we formed the payload.
So the payload is a dictionary containing
inputs with text message content, which is
the message that the bot has received.
And we formed the request headers by again,
using the Huggy face API key.
So we read the Huggy face token from the environment,
process dot m dot hugging face token and form
the headers.
Right before we start making the HTTP request,
we set the bot status to typing.
Now record a server.
So the response is the result from this call
to fetch using HTTP POST, given the payload
as the body and the headers using the Huggy
face token.
And we convert the response into JSON format,
and extract out the generated text field.
If there isn't a generate a text field in
the response, but is that the response contains
a narrower field.
This means that the board has encountered
some errors, and we may want to print out
the error for further debugging.
Now that we have the bots response, we can
clear out his typing status and sent the message
to the channel as a reply.
This ends the definition of our client dot
our message call.
Down here, we log in using the discord token.
Now let's invite the boss to our server.
So we go to o auth.
Check the bot, it only permission is to send
messages.
We copy this paste in a new browser window
and invite it to our server.
Great looks like we have another bot.
Remember to click on save changes.
Otherwise, the bots icon wouldn't be showing.
Now that we have our bot, however, it's not
logged in.
So we need to go back to the repple to run
our script.
But before we run our repple, let's make sure
that the bot doesn't have access to the general
channel.
Nor does it have access to the Python channel
because it's not supposed to go there.
So in permissions, we find this chat about
JavaScript.
Remove its permission to send messages.
And always remember to save the changes.
We do the same thing for it on the Python
channel
and go to the jazz channel.
This time, the one we need to remove is the
Python bot.
So this Python bot shouldn't be able to send
messages to this JavaScript channel.
Now we go back to run our raphoe dotnet.
If you see this error, this means that the
discord version that NPM is trying to install
is wrong.
You can see that there are those warnings
that the newest discord module is not compatible
with rapida its version of node, or NPM.
So we need to manually change something in
package dot JSON.
So here, we just use the older version and
rerun it.
Now that we are logged in as chatty about
JavaScript 1048 let's go back to our discord
channel.
Call the chat about is also online.
Let's see if a response to our messages.
Alright, right.
So this is now an error message telling us
that the model is still loading.
The model will usually take one or two minutes
to load.
So let's give it some time.
Great looks like our bot is responding to
us.
And because we have set the bots permissions
correctly, the Python bot is not responding
to any messages here.
And the JavaScript bots shouldn't be able
to talk here.
And in our general channel, nobody is ever
allowed to talk here.
Cool.
So now we have successfully built the bot
both in Python and in JavaScript.
One thing to note is that if I close the browser
tab for the Python bot, the bot is no longer
responding, although it still shows that the
bot is online.
So in the next part, we're going to look at
how to keep the bots running indefinitely
in the browser, even when we close the browser
tab.
In order to get our bot to run indefinitely,
we need to create a web server in raphoe dotnet,
and set up a service called uptime robot to
continuously ping the web server.
So this is for the Python bot.
And we create a new file called people live
dot p y.
And we add the code for a web server like
this.
And in our main.py, we import that part.
And down here in the main function, right
before the bot runs.
We ask it to be kept alive.
We run it.
When the code runs, we see a URL shown in
this tab.
And we copy this URL and bring it to our uptime
robot service.
So here is the uptime robots website.
And I already have an account.
So I'll just go to my dashboard and add a
new monitor.
Monitor montra type is going to be HTTPS friendly
name, this court, Python but the URL is the
one we copied from here.
And monetary level will be a ping every five
minutes that should be sufficient.
And finally we create, monitor
and close it.
Now let's see if our Python bot is capable
of running indefinitely.
Alright, I'm going to close this top containing
my Python script.
And it looks like our model is still up.
It's just that after some time, the model
or Huggy face backend will reload because
the bot itself is responding.
We know that our web server approach has worked
Now let's repeat this process for the JavaScript
bot.
We create a new file called server.js and
copy paste base code waiting for import this
part from the file that we just created.
Finally, right before to bought Roz, we are
going to call keep alive.
Stop this service.
And right.
Alright, the server is now ready.
We copy this URL, go to uptime robot and add
a new monitor.
It's again HTTP monitor this cord.
js bot, and the URL is like this.
We create a monitor.
Now we can safely close this browser window
and go back to our discord chat about is still
running.
Great.
Now we're all done.
We have a cool Python chat bot and a cool
JavaScript chat bot not can run indefinitely.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
Please subscribe for more content like this
and I'll see you in the next one.